ten years ago meditation was not
mainstream meditation was weird you
couldn't talk about spiritual awakening
without people thinking you were [ __ ]
crazy what's it gonna be like 10 years
from now and what role do you have in
that becoming what what do you know that
if the world knew you knew they would
think you're [ __ ] crazy that ten
years from now you'll know was so
necessary for the integration boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we are still
a consciousness hackings awakened future
summit we are now going to be talking to
Robin or not hello hi thank you so much
for coming on the show really thank you
very pumped you are the CEO of Andromeda
entertainment which does video games
from transformations and go ahead and
teach us about who you are and what you
represent oh sure who teach you about
who I am and what I represent oh boy
that's a big one I'll keep it straight
so I'm a I've been a video game designer
for the last 10 years or so I've been
deeply in the independent video games
world so I worked on the game
antichamber Stanley parable as a sound
designer and what I loved about being a
sound designer was we're visual thinkers
which means that musicians and sound
designers can sneak right past the part
of you that thinks and kind of grab you
by the back of your mind and and I loved
back when I was doing the sound design
for video games
I loved how I could I could just warp a
person's reality and help them feel
different or more or whatever so that
was kind of the beginning of my career
in experiences and after my first
oneness experience a game design flashed
into my head which became sound self and
after years of developing sound self I
am meeting the most incredible people
because you can feel very alone or I
felt very alone for a long time you know
making this this piece of this
interactive experience that was designed
directly to
shifter state of consciousness and I was
surrounded by brilliant people and I
mean the independent game scene is full
of incredibly brilliant artists I don't
know if you're a gamer but just like
yeah independent game scene is it won't
fire and they don't fire for about a
decade and those are my friends you know
so I've had the incredible privilege of
being surrounded by a huge amount of
artistic genius um and but I was trying
to do something different you know I
wasn't trying to tell a story I wasn't
trying to provoke an emotional response
I wasn't trying to stimulate any sort of
mental response I was trying to bypass
all of that and help they use a video
game to help a person feel what they are
and as I started doing that at first
feeling very alone I started
encountering more and more people
thinking about not just game design but
music and art in general in this
transformative way I think many of us
inspired by psychedelics since here at
the awakened future summit I think many
of us inspired by meditation which is
downright become mainstream in the last
10 years it wasn't ten years ago think
about that
and I was frustrated because I I
realized like I needed like a big
brother
I needed a company that could help bring
sound self to market given that self was
so different from what people expect
from video games it needed a very
different treatment and as with the you
know origin story of so many companies
just not not being out there there was
an opportunity to step up and create it
and so I took a break from developing
sound self for about a year - instead
develop the business entity that could
help projects like sound self get out
into the market so sound selves our
second game we were also working on a
dance experience that's our first game
which is audio trip and we're working on
finding the next tier of titles for us
to work with to help flesh out the
transformational experience market
because once you had once you have an
experience that shakes you out of your
narrative
there's nothing like it I don't see
people wanting to go back to you know
like distraction experiences or what
have you the most beautiful distraction
experiences are like like you know this
once you start meditating or taking
psychedelics or so on like they it is a
spiritual path and you get onto the
spiritual path and I don't know anybody
who gets onto that path and then gets
bored of it right so I think that this
is going to be at a tremendously potent
market and we're just seeing the
beginnings of it right now
dama once you speak to how when we are
involved in a video game that there's so
many pieces to the video game that we're
typically not very aware of and similar
to when we dine at a restaurant and that
we're not usually getting behind the
eyes of the chef and the busser and the
waiters and waitresses and very
intentionally so the more that we can
intentionally understand the puzzle
pieces of the video game designers and
developers the audio engineers all that
type of stuff the more we can
potentially have a better understanding
of exactly what yeah the intention of
even the game is and so why don't you
teach us about that first there's so
many cool things that you said and we'll
try and break them down as you go but
that first part you your awareness has
been expanded to the point where you
know that with audio you can potentially
bypass some of these initial processing
that we have and we're playing a game
then you can transform people state to
speak to that a little bit sure
let me find it musicians know this
politicians know this anybody who so we
were we have a mind of course and can I
just assume your audience understands
like the difference between who they are
in the mind or should I like explain
that a little bit explain that a little
bit okay so you know we we have our mind
which creates differences between things
and says this is this and that is that
and here's how I relate to this and
here's not really than that here's how
these things relate to each other and
creates these really do beautiful
intricate maps and so much so many of us
are identified with the mind and we
don't realize until our mind stops for a
moment that's not what we are that were
something much much bigger I don't know
to what degree that that is cultural
versus to what degree its developmental
um but but it's there what is that that
you're referencing that's bigger than no
mine oh man you know it has well the
mind is the thing that does the naming
so I it the thing that's bigger than the
thing that does the naming can be named
although we try to name it it's out the
unity yeah yeah god source unity those
are great names um I like silly names as
well I used to I used to just call it
dr. banana hat because it's totally
ridiculous in my mouth but uh it's just
you know silence or you can kind of
describe these things but you're not
describing theirs they I forget the neti
neti meditation or not that not that not
that because of course as soon as you
that's silence but it's also the you
know there's no unfortunately I can't
there are people who do an incredible
job pointing at the stillness and
sometimes I can do that but most of the
time not so um but I can speak to once
once we begin to recognize we're more
than the mind and recognize everyone
else is more than the mind then we
realize we don't have to interface mind
to mind
anymore how do we interface that solo
soul or we we just I mean even
emotionally when we're relating to one
another on an emotional level that that
transcends our words you know through
things like the eye gazing the other
things like eye gazing we're just
sharing presence with one another
sharing presence without words love
being just being in silence music
together we got we get taken on a
journey together as the you and I did at
the journey this morning that he's
forced it as a designer um if we think
about how we relate to a person's mind
we're really limited in how we could
affect them and not only that but we are
necessarily interfacing with the
gatekeeper to that person's experience
and there's some merit to that because
if I want to convince you of something
you can make an argument that it's
ethical to go through the mind because
um maybe it's not ethical for me to
bypass your rational systems and just
plant an idea
emotionally although there are people
who can do that um but when you're
trying to give somebody a transformative
experience the gatekeeper is a nuisance
and and those of us working in media in
video games or music the the gatekeeper
is you know if you're listening to a
piece of music I don't know I I can I
can feel my gatekeeper on when the piece
of music is playing sometimes if I'm
getting critical about a piece of music
or if I'm like what oh you know it's
just like but not that noise is not the
thing that sweeps you up and it's the
same when you're watching movie playing
a video game listening oh here's a great
example like listening to for those new
audience who are religious or you know
that's something we lose in the secular
world is the sermon a sermon is is
spoken word that passes through or
the mind and into the into so all thing
about the soul that just recognizes
what's being said interesting yeah okay
okay the word gatekeeper is so funny
yeah because it's almost as though the
ability for us to work build a bore
build a stronger community this
communion with the gatekeeper a stronger
relationship with it because we we don't
necessarily want a potentially a a
gatekeeper that is too vigilant a
gatekeeper that's too loose but yeah the
gatekeeper serves a purpose it serves a
purpose for identifying what salient and
pursuing that may be this is the this is
trust who not really trust right not
trust there's so much so many things
here but I want you're you're starting
to hint at this how does one then figure
out how to embed something like a music
yeah that can get past like a sermon
like you said yeah I'd love that
question
I mean it's um I'll do my best to answer
you but to me it's so here's why I like
working with artists um I like working
with artists because artists um the good
artists are always creating from a place
of inspiration and if you ask them what
were you trying to do with this or that
you might be able to come up with an
answer but they're probably making it up
right they're just these just moving
through them so there's there's a kind
of divine inspiration that happens and
moves through the skill of the artists
to create something so it's not created
by the mind
although the mind can be enlisted as a
servant in the creation of it versus
creating something like like we've
noticed that 20 to 24 year old males are
looking for things that are like Call of
Duty but like this and so we're gonna
create a you know going from either
market strategy or from science or from
any of these things and coming down in
like like like using the design process
to answer a question instead of using
the divine design process divine process
did you ever scare the using the design
process to kind of work on an inquiry or
something like that you know they're
very different ways of approaching
things I forget your question now there
is it you you describe this as a
channeling through one into the world
were yeah versus a well that remind me
of your question question with it the
question is that there's there's
potentially a process that has yet to be
identified well that can do that that's
that's why I'm asking gatekeeper oh yeah
I remember that okay so it is it's a
subtle and kind of mysterious process
but I'll do my best to describe it oh it
has something to do with so each of us
in our core as I meet you as we meet
each other through our eyes and through
that or through our identities and as
I'm speaking to you mind to mind
gatekeeper to gatekeeper we're meeting
the place where we're separate where
we're different which means that this is
a really great and exciting place to
communicate ideas right because when you
feel the difference between ideas and
you feel that tension that's exciting
but there's another way in which is
instead of if I feel deep into myself
and feel that which is channeling
through it's something that is it comes
from a more universal place and so
there's a way that if I put my mental
capacities in in service to that or my
skill in service to that I'm executing
something and creating something which
is from a place that's more expansive
and more wise than the mind is that is
more recognizable and more intimate even
so one could say that there are the the
minds that are here together and then
there's the I think mind is necessarily
oppositional oh isn't it I think it is
I'm just I just don't thought about that
before but it's good yeah yeah but then
there is all their potential of a deeper
from some sort of a spiritual emotional
transcendent vibe between the between
people that if you can potentially relay
a message from that area to the others
like that huh in fact for well while
we're all habitually identified with the
mind what that means doing is attending
to the mode of inspiration and serving
that and attending to intuition as it
arises and serving that especially when
I was about to say even one but actually
especially when it doesn't make sense
and especially when you don't understand
it
oh and then you've turned your mind into
something that is in service of I've run
out of words but in service of the
mystery or in service of of that which
wants to happen that can't be
articulated with the limited would
something like that yeah so then okay
delivering music from soul to soul music
or art or all right yeah yeah some soul
to souls
okay so then teach us so now this is
what you're fascinated yeah and you're
actually so so is this right that
Andromeda entertainment is making it
easier for people to do this process
well we're we're a publishing company or
an agency so we're connecting with the
artists that are working in this space
and by this space I mean transformative
interactive art and connecting those
into the the emerging market for those
experiences so you know like like
Burning Man has been such a cultural
sensation this last twenty thirty years
and has had a huge impact on out on
culture and I see so many industries
emerging that are inspired by Burning
Man or by you know just this or this raw
kind of sensational experience a
sensational sensational they do with the
senses um so cannabis lounges whatever
the modern church is whatever the place
we come together to worship and be
in it relate to spirit in community
whatever that is and that's something
that's just kind of emerging you know so
whatever that is um I want to connect
these artists including myself with
sound self but don't just me you know to
that and use these things together to
kind of help I hope it come into being
okay yes yes okay so walk us through it
walk us through examples of you know
even before we get to the people that
you engage with through Andromeda to do
the the next-gen of interactive art for
the soul to soul let's talk about let's
talk about sound self let's talk about
sure what what you've built yeah in this
space yeah great thank you
sound self came to me I had my first
oneness experience on LSD which was a
little bit of a shocker
as it tended to be it's just like a Hulk
I didn't know that that's uh that's
interesting I don't know what to do with
his information set the line afterwards
um but um it was some time after that
when I was just pondering a sort of game
design space I've been thinking about
when my oneness experience came to me
and I realized I it didn't just happen I
kind of followed a path into it and for
me that path had a lot to do with voice
because I was on LSD and I was in a
space at Burning Man and began toning
just to feel myself ground and as I
began toning the music in that very
moment filled with voices that happened
to harmonize with my voice and I in that
moment for the first time I felt with
such clarity that I'm not just this
voice or just this body and and I felt
the sense of agency that I usually
identify with and that seems to be the
kind of the core of causation in my
being as just like one other thing
that's happening and um and but that was
a path that I kind of was led down
or walk down and that that path could be
I could create a design a system that
would walk all the people down that path
and for me it was voice and so it is
what sound selfs and soul starts with
your voice and you use your voice in
long tones
as you tone just the world shifts and
dance and moves around you you feel that
responding to you it starts harmonizing
with you and as well it's flashing at
you so giving you all these abstract
geometries so you can't your mind has
nothing to settle on and you're
constantly toning which slows your
breathing down and by the way everything
all my explanation for why it works
nurses are things that came in years
afterwards because what it came to me as
an inspiration yeah you know that's just
like this right and so so it's and this
is what I mean like the correct way it
has to come from inspiration and then if
you want to figure you can't start with
why I think it's not the incorrect order
of operations is to start from why and
then build it's break you know you have
to start with the inspiration and then
you can figure out why later on I think
that's how good art is made but I might
be full of [ __ ] so as you're doing that
as you're toning and the voices in this
really precious place where it's
embodied and you feel it but it's also
out here and you hear it so it's already
on the boundary between where you
perceive self another to be and and we
see the world respond to our voice and
with our voice all the time so there's
there's already something magic in voice
it's just we're so used to it then we
don't pay attention to it but once you
change the context a little bit and
overwhelm the senses suddenly you notice
something you didn't before and in this
iteration of the software you notice in
a way that that's not like ah I think of
like a psychedelic can be like my
psychedelic first oneness experience was
it was very much a revelation Wow and
then closing down and and integration
this one's more it's more subtle you
know but it is authentically doing what
a ketamine does or what LSD does or even
what DMT does um not in the same way but
it is bringing the mind into silence
so that awareness can feel what it is
and through my long I'm bringing my mind
into silence it's partly that and it's
also partly the the visual stimulation
and it's also partly the this is very
important you said that there's no it's
abstractly Anadarko shapes you make it
so that the mind is saying nothing
square circle triangle I can't label it
exactly because that's what mine does
mind label so when you give the mind
some place there's nothing your label
it's changing too fast at labels
changing too fast and so my oh yes my my
changes cause the abstract geometry to
change as well so then this game is
played in a virtual reality space and
then available across will be yeah it'll
be available on oculus and alive and on
ps4 PS VR and we're working on other
implementations of it because I think
like these sorts of transformative
technologies the place to experience
them is not going to be necessarily just
in the living room it's going to be in
community together or in cannabis
lounges or something you know the most
magical places to experience these are
well then we can somehow build a ritual
around them so I'm thinking beyond sound
self and into this as a whole genre
they're hungry for more than just like
the casual and engagement of a video
game they're hungry to be treated as
ceremony which and then what's the
economic infrastructure of that ceremony
look like I don't know the answers
mm-hmm but I'm paying close attention
okay so then your your career in the
last ten years of doing things like
video game design and audio engineering
is synthesizing its way into a deeper
spiritual practice and you want to
deliver the spiritual practice to others
through the mediums which you've gained
experience in the year 10 years and
which are such a medium that already
attract people like video games like VR
ok and sound selfish was the first or
was there one you said sound self was my
is an experience I've been designing for
eight years but as a publisher and Roman
entertainment it's our second title is
their second title yeah okay and the
first title again was it's called audio
trip and it's like ants experience
experience okay okay and then this one
they are an audio trip Oh an audio -
audio trip say you you dance you move
your body it's it's less psychedelically
inclined and it's more just about
getting into your body and feeling live
and feeling in a few yeah that's great
yeah just always there's so many ways
that video games can be used to bring
people up to life there's so many ways
that we can looking like harmonized with
the human experience to produce
something that's that's really deep and
really um it just helps us feel
ourselves in a way that is it's just so
much more present and so much more like
gosh I don't even have the words for it
you know I think the standard use of
video games is to distract us or to
entertain us
and by entertain I mean like help us not
feel as much pain for the moment none of
us a little bit um but it's just a tool
it doesn't have to be used that way you
can it can absolutely be used to help
you feel more real and film can - so
Phil you gave - social media can do but
God's social media has a long way yeah
yeah interesting so the
the identify school identifying
videogames as a tool that can be used to
do things like send a deep love ball
into someone else's soul okay so so now
this what are we thinking in a couple
months or so for sound self yes before
the idea okay so before the end of the
year and where can people see up to date
on what you can check out our Facebook
which is you just look up sound self on
Facebook look up sound self on Facebook
on Instagram if you follow Andromeda
I think it's Instagram is enter
Andromeda enter Andromeda on Instagram
okay oh we're twitter which is at cell
itself or or level twitter is that video
dreaming though I don't tweet very much
anymore at sound cell and so on Twitter
okay okay so this is how people can keep
in up-to-date with where you guys are at
this sounds I want to do though I want
to do that we can on Sunday your
listeners can't necessarily maybe they
can but in the different context but
well we're having a party on Sunday at
the end of this thing yeah love for you
to attend let's try this explain to you
thank you nice yeah so okay so now where
are we heading
with the leveraging the medium for these
spiritual love balls wow yeah that yeah
teach us about what how we're gonna use
video game in music to do this in
virtual reality
mmm-hmm how we're going to use video
games and music it's it's so with any of
these things the tool is there um I
think this is true not only of any of
the arts but any any in place you have a
skill or an expertise if you redirect
that skill or expertise towards mystery
then its
we become something sacred and I've been
as a as a first-time entrepreneur I've
been finding that to be the case with
business you know that's hugely but with
video games
honestly all it is is is having a
spiritual practice and and and having
your life be a spiritual practice um and
like I can't tell you like what the
techniques are I mean I could but I
don't think that's really then you'll
just learn how to make something that is
like like really the the truest thing
always comes from the inside and from
inside ourselves and and um there might
be something to learn by studying my
work but but I really think that that
the the truest thing is it comes from
having a relationship with reality that
is devotional and having that be the
totality of one's life and if you're a
video game designer or if you're an
artist or if you're a musician and
that's the way you approach being alive
you'll channel that's just what the
creation process will be will be a
channeling process you won't always
understand it yeah in fact the moment
you understand it is is the moment you
you've lost the edge and just fine we
need to do that to integrate you know we
need to like channel for a little bit
than integrate the channel that
integrate that's that's right like you
can't be tripping all the time and
people who are beyond certain stages of
enlightenment don't necessarily hold
jobs very well but but but the point is
if you're if you live in a devotional
manner your work will become devotional
it almost can't not but it requires like
so much bravery and the willingness just
to gosh it's it's both easy and and so
difficult right um and like you said you
have to do things like have the creative
process be channeled through you and
then find a way to
to take yourself from the edge maybe do
a little bit of integration of it back
to the edge this is a very delicate
process of edge work plus integration
shadow work integrations surrender
everything ice all speak about you know
speak about the artistic creation
process but for you think we're gonna
experience all of this with video game
music with any virtual reality yeah with
absolutely anything that you have as a
practice and then anything created from
that place is going to is going to be a
is going to a and other people on their
journey as well we listen to East Forest
this morning and that's music that is
absolutely created from from a
devotional practice and it helps you and
it helps me touch something deep in
ourselves and and and then touch the
places we have resistance to that depth
so yeah that's that's just what I say
it's like it is as soon as as soon as
your your labor and your creation
becomes a devotional practice it can't
help but catch fire but not be in the
way that you would your mind would want
it to catch fire but there's something
that's trying to happen here and we
don't understand it and um push to the
unbound with love to push there that
we're trying to understand I don't know
feels like that's kind of what's
happening to push towards unity and that
that seems to be something that's
happening yeah yeah but I'm not sure I
even think that that whatever that which
is trying to happen is is you know this
is just what it looks like to me is is
unity as an aspect of that but so is our
separateness yeah totally and so is
correct yeah so it's an awakening in
general that maybe the one can say
that's whatever the [ __ ] it is it's huge
yeah and it's powerful and end and we
can't control it and it's smarter than
us and it's wiser than us and it's more
real than us and it moves through us and
it speaks through us and if we resist it
we suffer and if we surrender to it we
come to life with each other in a way
that's the undescribable and if we if we
bring our work into harmony with it then
the meaning of work is different and and
the meaning of our output is is is
different and we've gotten a little oh
my gosh yes it's too good
yeah the meaning of our output is
different our life sorry this could be
true if you're a banker you know or an
accountant or a or a maid or like it's
not in the arts it's very clear and very
obvious because art that doesn't come
from that place is ugly hmm but it but
and you can make a living as a banker
without coming from you know what I mean
but this is this thing that I'm saying
is true of any practice yeah of any
practice so that it's like if we walk
away from our most divine actualized
path if we don't let it channel through
us then it can get sometimes ugly but
now we could stay on that topic that
topic yeah how do the how does it draw
an entertainment then work with all
these indeed creators that you were
talking about earlier in order to help
them with this push towards that towards
that you need towards whatever's coming
through us in the video games music sure
are I don't I don't see I don't I don't
think I can like creatively coach people
I think for that part I have to find the
people who are already making something
that's really in alignment with this and
then then there's just an intuitive
practice an intruder process of see like
how do how do we want to work together
what's emerging around us that that um
that needs like let's say you're an
artist that I want to work with I'm
aware of you know this opportunity this
opportunity this opportunity this
distribution model this thing that's
coming up a few years because it's like
as like it's my job to stay zoomed out
yeah and and if you're an artist it's
your job to stay zoomed in mmm
and um so when we come together and and
when we feel that alignment then um well
practically speaking there's funding
there's a distribution through through
mainstream outlets like steam of the
oculus store and so on but the place I'm
most excited about are these emerging
places like I was mentioning the juice
passe cannabis lounges psychedelic
clinics you know how do any of these
technologies fit into the the awakening
that's happening you know here we're
here the awakened future summit which is
about psychedelics there's a lot of
psychedelic therapists here and any of
these things that can be a tool for
somebody psychedelic awakening I want to
help make that happen I mean art is is
already without labeling it as such we
already know that art has to play a role
in psychedelic ceremony this is why we
have music this is why we have like
beautiful settings and so on so so what
does high-tech art in that space do for
for the psychedelic of phenomenon that's
happening in America today so these are
some of the spaces that I see merging
and and for the moment it's very of
exploratory excuse me explorative and
experimentally and you're staying
outside be able to watch how these are
popping up and then and then collect
this title in this way and this title
this way these titles together in this
way and how do we you know Inlet plug
the indie artists through those channels
and whatnot exactly okay
yeah and the very early it's very late
I like how you also said that the
artists that you work with they have to
have their own actualization their own
artistic edge that yeah they have to
channel through them and that you can
then work with them actually I feel like
that happens a lot of the time now is
we're seeing kind of a play between a
mentor and a mentee it's actually a
really important phenomenon for us to
continue making a priority in our lives
as a mentee mentor phenomenon so like
one could talk to you about what what
they're passionate about where they
could see a fit and then you could help
that whole process is so important it it
it catalyzes significant success in life
the phenomenon into Sigma and stuff so
so okay so now we have this we have this
era of VR and and psychedelics and
meditation and it's pretty exciting
right it's pretty cool to be part of the
weakening yeah uh-huh and we're the
frogs of the frying-pan right always
where the frogs on the frying pan but
like 10 years ago meditation was not
mainstream meditation was weird you
couldn't talk about spiritual awakening
without people thinking you were [ __ ]
crazy what's it gonna be like 10 years
from now and what role do you have in
that becoming what what do you know that
if the world knew you knew they would
think you're [ __ ] crazy that 10 years
from now you'll know was so necessary
for the integration sorry dentro that's
a huge part of what we also are very
passionate about I'm trying to inspire
other people to to catch on like what do
you know now that in 10 years people are
gonna catch on to and that and that'll
be really important for the overall
awakening and and to try and manifest
that not in 10 years but at 6 months or
yes yeah manifest because it because I
think all of these things that we're
doing and I don't think we we know here
the connections that are
right now but like I'm working on this
piece you know Adam gazali downstairs is
working on this piece and then somebody
I don't know I don't know what they're
doing is working on this piece and
someone's working on this piece and
they're all gonna come together in some
way and and it's such a it's such a you
know like I just have to surrender to
that process and keep my eyes open and
try to be as humble as possible yes yes
yes Peschel only see young people that
are smarter than we are
oh my god they're so smart they're so
smart really smart yeah yeah okay a
couple thoughts that I think we should
talk about on the way out one is are we
in a simulation oh yeah
are we in a simulation so this is a
simulation podcast I can I can give you
a yes and I can give you a no and I'm
trying to decide which to give you or
both okay so I mean okay obviously maybe
not obviously actually this is not
obvious but for anyone who's done like
their work in psychedelics and
meditation and so on like this is unjust
I it seems we seem to understand this
that that that which we think is real
and that which we think we are is not
it's just like it's just you know the
the Buddhist idea of like ripples on the
surface of the water it's there but it's
not it's it's an illusion nor it's a
it's just a piece of it or it's the it's
it's I mean I mean I'm looking for the
words it's it's like it's just not what
it seems to be you know but
it's not purposeless you know and it's
not empty and it's not oh but I think
I've seen you okay so so here's my no as
it like when I think of simulation
simulations are where we simulating
something there are always like a a sort
of low poly representation of something
that is more real like a race car sin is
like the simulation of driving a racecar
I don't think this is a simulation of
anything I think this is something
crucially important and magical and
special that's happening here through us
that we don't understand but it's also
not what it seems to be okay and what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
Oh
I have a step four year old stepson
he's sometimes so annoying and total
dick and that moment in me when my
resistance to him gives way to something
else and I see the magic and I see the
wisdom and and I respect him as a as a
being who is just as alive and and
tapped into or something whatever you
know just as blank as I am and and that
moment going from [ __ ] you Jesus to that
to me that's the most beautiful thing in
the world there's so much everywhere in
our world where we see conflict is is
like the first side of that you know
thanks for asking that's a good question
it's a really good question it's a good
answer to be able to to feel that and
then be able to explain it the
transition that you feel in your feeling
between those moments oh yeah yeah and
what I think he's a dick I'm not
thinking about the but I'm gonna love
him in a minute and see that you know
see the beauty of this I'm just thinking
driven selfish a little dick it's part
of it I think you know we people talk a
lot about like the the political divide
right now where everyone just thinks
each others like such a dick and missing
the point and I'm it's like that's half
the picture yeah yeah Robin this has
been a wonderful conversation I've been
enjoying it thank you so much for coming
on in the show and talking to us
my pleasure we're really looking forward
to sound self I want everyone to check
out the links in the bio get checking
get get that get keep more conversations
rolling around a friends families
co-workers people online on social media
about what these things are like when we
applied video games and music for
transformation
for transformation and check out the
links flow to conscious hacking also to
simulation support the artists
organizations and entrepreneurs are on
the world that you believe in and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in and we will see you soon
and and please I've got one more yes
please be in touch if whatever your
manifesting the future is if it's in the
domain of what I've been speaking about
maybe we can manifest together that's
right all the infos below - Robins work
check it out much love